mom mama when are we gonna get you as a
guest for a askgaryvee show
I think it's time
I know when I do that it's just like
kind of like [ __ ] like please do this
for yourself
please let me will you to this place I'm
there I don't need anything I you
desperately want you to because the
thing I get from it is you telling me
thank you and I feed off that and when I
hit that in a video that's when I most
um feel it so I think of it as more of a
self-fulfilling prophecy it's why I'm
pushing everybody for comments and
feedback because it feeds me it feeds me
it's like laughs it's why I try to be
funny on stage or get reactions like I
can build like in my talks like you know
most of my talk so unless something
weird happen in that I'm funny guy right
yeah
do you wreck your think I'm a funny guy
I'm a funny guy
you want India forever and always
you only cause it that's right don't
back off of that be like yep yeah that's
how you stick it to people people it's
like oh you won I'm like uh-huh yeah and
they're like you know that when they try
to be condescending like okay you wanna
like yep I sure did
I want directly your [ __ ] mouth good
Marcus how are you my man over here good
to see you let's do it
2:11 everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 211 of the
askgaryvee show
I love you smart man
mob you talk you soon India where's the
car
your gifts gonna be to give back it's
what I've been doing more yeah you you
need to spend some real time together
it's what I'm doing in parallel I say
see I'm Gary thank you nice to meet you
how are you really well chef I
appreciate I'll talk to you soon
hello and how are you good
what's up snapchat go check my Facebook
account right this second with more
important videos that pumped out a long
time check it
I'll go speaker for dailyvee crew this
is fun this is one of my favorite things
I've been doing sits back in a oh wait
oh nine just give me your number and
I'll call you it's an amazing
opportunity to connect peeps it's just a
lot of fun it's just like doing fun
stuff
seven minutes you know can check email
got a lot of work to do no question but
this is this is where you make decisions
about your community or your execution
or bill language here like you're always
making decisions you're always taking
different things just a mood thing
there's no right answer I'm not right
with my style but everybody's got their
own things so let's see what happens
Manuel
Daniel I'm really calling you how are
you yeah I mean poor Tyler's drinking
out of a fire hose we're getting
thousands of emails a day he's just
starting his assistant so and he's
killing it by the way but we'll take a
look at it
like I mean I'm all talk to Brandon send
me an e-mail directly Gary at
vaynermedia calm and I'll take care of
it right I'm good man
I'm what you could do for me is say
thanks and then I'm gonna call some
other homie so hope you have a great day
brother if you're falling out of Andrew
this is Gary Vaynerchuk super well and
you I love that that's always a good
thing everything well in your world when
you're in man it's a grind you know the
the ebb and flow and the ups and downs
man if it was so easy everybody would do
it keep grinding what do you do
good for you man good luck to know right
Thank You Man take care wait Nate from
our office my former intern int and then
my former assistant and now one of the
keys cogs to uh Manor media that me I
don't know let's see if the answers
it's time to be on Twitter but not
answered a phone eight this is Gary
Vaynerchuk I see you want to meet it to
call you yes do you need some help the
questions that could be unbailing me
good well so no but will added that part
I hold on
go ahead what's up sorry buddy neat you
need to stole everyone's time just good
bad guy not me
seems to be
thanks Mary
thank you that's your name Mike Mikey
nice to meet you I see
thank you brother thank you so much
energy through thank you brother
I wish you well
I mean they up there with you today oh
well yeah great to see you what's
happening your fireside chat Amy like
you you're gonna ask questions on my rib
and then we're gonna go into Q&A with
them yeah love the most showman and
bravado version of myself on stage when
the lights are on and people are looking
at me in my navigating of my businesses
I've been much more a tortoise in a
harris costume I look the part but I've
been very calculated I've been
obnoxiously patient when you really look
under the hood I'm sorry that the world
is changing but it is and and I think
that I don't have a whole lot of empathy
for laziness and dwelling I'm just
settling in because it's just a losing
mentality I think what's ended up
happening in my life is that I day trade
attention and what I mean by day trading
attention is when you're marketing we're
trying to tell a story I mean whether
you're trying to be the president United
States or raise money for your NGO or
your bake sale at your school or sell
bottled water or whatever you trying to
accomplish in life first being
somebody's attention and then the
creatives is the variable of your
success there's a very big difference
between being a branding and marketing
LED engine and a sales letter chip why
did I buy these sneakers I didn't buy
them because Nike [ __ ] cookies me on
a website and remarketed to me and I
finally gave up and bought it on their
site I have no idea why I bought these
and natural branding
like that one
like my Khrushchev it's my Russian DNA
it's a really nice yeah the guy that
artist it awesome so thank you thanks
for having me
thank you
well that's this nice Jesus that are you
building this day is beautiful that's
that's our new building right oh my god
okay yeah let's do it
wow this is really nice I feel like I
don't want to leave can I just sit here
inside with you billion books alright
it's funny nice job man thank you very
much my pleasure hope you enjoyed it
thank you
nice do you rock that harness is legit
we're so ghetto I need to get you a
harness cool Stefan is coming on I love
it I love competition 4d rock makes me
happy alright thanks for pleasure IQ for
everything my pleasure
I mean I mean if you're yeah you know
why yes because I think you start with
snapchat it's gonna be a lot of you and
you start building the narrative of you
and your business yeah I think you
should do one big rant right now of like
here are my businesses here's what they
are it's like an established piece of
content download download that story put
on YouTube have something to point to
yeah cool get out of here yeah
yes I remember from London yeah that's
right Matt this was I didn't I didn't
remember that this was the talk that's
awesome man how are you thank you
yes thanks going hope you enjoy the talk
good thank you thank you nice to meet
you man how are you
it's possum era question thank you
brother
I wish you well good luck to you I
noticed thanks for the nice vibes it's
always good to have like that person's
like gives you some heavy support of
course J sweet simple really enjoyed it
thank you so much
Oh J cross the e o JN just a yeah no no
no II wear my life view hey awesome
thank you such a pleasure very much
enjoyed it thank you so much for H know
I didn't want to get the audio for sure
though thank you I'm like you reading
I'm not good at it you know me too
it's awesome really nice to meet you
take care alright Instagram let's do it
felis a man real pleasure yeah really
thanks for the love awesome so during is
what you do every day 100% oh that's
right and actually like really like not
like I I handle all my social media
accounts I look at the data like I do it
and then less I understand it better
right I just I think people just get too
far away from the work eventually and I
think the humility that's needed to
deploy that is a very big competitive
advantage and he's an amazing he's an
amazing player but I think people
misunderstand what having that alpha
that real alpha like everybody like like
everybody in my wine business was the
greatest of what they did in the wine
business until I left like you know what
I mean and Scotty had enough years of
body of work in Houston in Portland to
prove me wrong so I feel very
comfortable with my point of view yeah
my daughter that she's the net she's
number one in the country in fencing
she's gonna get you right yes
- Morgan good luck Imoh rgan yeah that's
amazing how old is she she's 15 she she
is she literally like is she like
Olympic potential yeah that's crazy
good luck man that's really cool
hey man Jason Jason thank you yeah well
ready Brock yes get up let's get a quick
picture man Reverso
we should probably do that love it thank
you my friend
what's fun you know let me preface this
by saying you know I know nothing about
martial arts but I know a whole lot
about business and I do know enough
about the common sense that the momentum
of your opponent is something you take
advantage of fundamentally
I want to expand on what that means
obviously saw that great interview with
that little guy oh my man how are ya
good good what's your name hundred nice
to meet you
how old are you love it hustlin already
love it okay so the first question now
is gonna how would your son and I'm
studying a business yep what advice
would you give that's a very very solid
opening question I would know you since
you were my son and I would look at
everything that you're interested in and
the first piece of advice I'd give you
is do something around that so like for
example let me reverse this on you what
do you love besides business and things
that make sure what else are you into
why do you like and how do you think
like how you how do you think you're
gonna lead up to buying them I don't
know how I'm gonna buy the Jets I don't
I do not I know that I by nature as a
businessman and a counter-puncher what I
mean by that is Oh karate do you do
karate yeah so I I don't know this
because I don't have never done karate
but what I hear by being a common-sense
individual in the world isn't a lot of
martial arts is predicated on using
other people's energy as your offense
right good that's who I am as a
businessman I'm the best I think I'm
gonna go down as one of the best karate
businessmen of all time because what I'm
extremely good at is responding to the
actions of the market and then finding
my opportunities I never thought that I
would be producing content that I'd be
into social media that I would have an
agency that I would write books I
reacted to the opportunity got it yeah
so there was no plan the plan was pay
attention to what's going on find the
opportunity
and strike it yeah I mean I'm starting
to really understand that that's what I
do well sometimes I talk about riding
the wave and I talk about camera
punching I wanted to go a little bit
deeper for all of you that's what this
whole daily view projects about not just
the headlines or the kind of quotable
comments but go a little bit deeper I
think it's very powerful to ride a horse
you know I'm sure martial arts and it's
pretty understandable in boxing like use
the other person's momentum to set up
what you want riding a wave I talked
about technology running you over unless
you ride it that's how I think about
business you take momentum and you
figure out how to use it to your
advantage
I don't predict I'm go on the offense
I'm not trying to force VR or social
media or e-commerce
I often talk about not selling to
somebody who can't be sold anybody that
doesn't understand we've evolved every
day forever always and forever
like everybody wants the world to stop
you know everybody wants the world to
stop for their vested interest you don't
like that it's happening your job may be
in jeopardy you're worried about your
kids
it doesn't matter technology's gonna do
its thing you know this all ties in
together right I'm not you know this is
gonna be interesting for a lot of you
I'm not the aggressor I'm the one who
takes on what's happening and so what
I'm doing is a whole lot of watching I'm
watching these people who walk in the
street like bowling culture like phone
culture like people on their phone this
is real this is not super hard I'm
really just absorbed with what are
people actually doing and then how do I
react to that I don't have any wants or
needs that they're actually doing that
I'm not trying to force people to start
doing that what I'm doing is I'm
reacting to what people are actually
doing and I do think from a kind of
religious and and here's a good
opportunity when I say religion I need
strategy right from a religious point
from a strategic which would be the way
most people say it from a strategic
point of view
this is what I'm trying to figure out
how do I take behavior that's already
happening how do I then bring the most
value to people and something that are
already doing I'm just sitting and
watching people on their phone like it's
just it's just the way I see people
doing it I see the world very clear on
this intro it's kind of like when I see
those mute you know the sci-fi movies
were like they show them from the
perspective of that character and they
see different things I kind of literally
think that that's what's happening with
me that I feel like I'm just seeing
different things when once I make that
strategic point of view that religious
point of view I then go pop committed
and go all in and figure out how to use
your collective momentum to create the
opportunities for me and my partner's
that's what my life's about
I didn't discovered email I didn't
create email I was an email advocate I
knew that you were using email so I
figured out how to sell you wine in it
you know I didn't create Facebook videos
I didn't invent it another advocate of
it I know you watch it because I make
this and so that's how I see the world
and that's what I meant by reacting to
people's momentum in martial arts I mean
fighting its your opponent the other
person for me as a business person who
thinks it's scale to try to build big
businesses it's done on a market level
all of you
you